McTeer you need to produce specific
enzymes in order to meet its metabolic
demand and also to reproduce but in
order to produce specific enzymes or
proteins bacteria need to produce the
raw materials first the amino acids and
among these the amino acids one of such
amino acid is tryptophan now the process
by which bacteria produces tryptophan is
known as trip operon now what is trip
operon so trip operon first of all it's
an open system that means multiple genes
are controlled by a single promoter and
all this product of the trip operon
genes are the enzymes which converts the
kharisma acid into tryptophan in a
sequential step so using this tryptophan
operon bacteria is able to produce
tryptophan which would be utilized
during protein synthesis now we would be
talking about the transcriptional
regulation of these tryptophan operon
genes now let's assume a situation when
the tryptophan level is high it has been
seen at that situation the open on
status is off and whenever the
tryptophan level is low the open on
status is on that means the tryptophan
open on genes are transcribed and all
necessary enzymes to convert cosmic acid
to tryptophan is produced it makes sense
because whenever there is plenty of
tryptophan bacteria won't waste it
energy to produce more tryptophan but it
would produce more tryptophan when the
tryptophan level is low and it needs
tryptophan so we can understand this
operon is active in our on-demand basis
and also this openin is an repressible
operon by default state the open on is
on only the open on is off when there is
plenty of tryptophan and there is no
more demand of the tryptophan now let's
just look at what happens when the
tryptophan level is low now when the
tryptophan level is low
then these genes which produce a chorus
make acid which produce tryptophan from
charisma as it would be transcribed more
but how does that happen
so like lac operon here also there is a
repressor the repressor is a Apple
repressor in absence of tryptophan so it
cannot become a hollow repressor at
cannot suppress the transcription of
these genes
so when tryptophan level is low the
repressor is inactive and it cannot
suppress the transcription as a result
transcription happens but whenever the
tryptophan level is high it can bind to
the receptor repressor and the repressor
now becomes a hollow repressor as a
result it binds to the operator region
of the trip operon and RNA polymerase
cannot bind to that now and as a result
the trip operon genes are not
transcribed now if we zoom into details
of this process we can understand the
promoter and the operator region has a
sequence known as the leader sequence
so whenever RNA polymerase is
transcribing this leader RNA this leader
RNA has 2 4 specific sites which can
pair with each other 1 1 2 3 4 these are
the four sites and 2 3 can pair with
each other
also 1 & 2 & 3 & 4 can pair with each
other and they are known as anti
attenuator stem loop and attenuator stem
loop respectively and this is the
structure attenuator stem loop which
results in pausing of the RNA polymerase
and not allowing to produce the genes of
the trip operon now we want to look at a
situation when the tryptophan level is
high it has been seen when the
tryptophan level is high attenuator stem
loop is formed that means region 1 & 2 &
3 & 4 are paired in this situation what
happens
is there is a small sequence highlighted
here in blue which is rich in uracil
that means there is a greater chance
that RNA polymerase would fall off from
that region and not transcribe
trip e to trip a these genes now
whenever tryptophan is low it has been
seen region two and three pairs and as a
result the downstream genes are
transcribed let's just look into details
what happens and why sometimes this
entire generator stem loop is formed
while sometimes attenuator stem loop is
formed now whenever tryptophan is low it
has been seen the anti attenuator stim
loop is formed wherever whenever
tryptophan is high attenuator stim loop
is formed and the RNA polymerase falls
off zooming into details we found that
whenever there is a high level of
tryptophan what happens so the leader
RNA is translated as well at the time of
the transcription because back in
bacteria transcription and translation
happens I must simultaneously now
imagine a situation when the tryptophan
level is high when the tryptophan level
is high the ribosome speed is pretty
high and it could easily move forward
quickly because all the amino acids need
to synthesize proteins are in pretty
much abundance so as a result region 2 3
& 4 can pair together and this
attenuator STM loop is formed but
imagine a situation when tryptophan is
low at that situation there is a
specific there is a specific site where
there is a specific site which codes for
codon corresponding to tryptophan but
you can understand the tryptophan level
is low as a result the amino acyl tRNA
which brings the tryptophan is also less
in abundance and as a result the rise of
ribosome speed is also low
which give rise to formation of the 2/3
anti attenuated stem-loop and as a
result RNA polymerase can move forward
and transcribe the downstream genes for
trip open on and when the tryptophan is
low this attenuation the repression of
this attenuation makes sense because RNA
polymerase can move forward make the
genes transcribe the genes which can
give rise to the proteins which are
necessary for conversion of cosmic acid
to tryptophan so that was my video about
trip operon I hope you enjoyed the video
if you like my video give it a quick
thumbs up don't like to like comment and
share thank you